[Music]
joining me this week is a comedian and
author a redneck and a liberal Craig
Crowder
welcome to the Reuben report I have glad
to be here my own a redneck and a
liberal yes that's throws people a lot
your wife even asked you a question to
start this thing or hey I just handed to
you there and well the so what has
become my favorite way to define that I
was actually was actually said to me at
one of my comedy shows in Austin Texas a
guy from Mississippi who lives in Austin
a fan came up to me and was talking to
me and he was like he seems so genuinely
frustrated to about like all the how
he's been stereotyped or whatever for
being a redneck whatever else he's got
man
I you know I I like to blow [ __ ] up but
I ain't [ __ ] racist man [ __ ] and he
seems like so upset about it I wanted to
put my hand on the shoulder like I know
buddy it's alright you know what I mean
but but yeah I basically just you know I
grew up in that was very stereotypically
redneck fashion you know dirt poor in
the middle of nowhere Tennessee and I
mean it would be redneck by basically
any standards but I've never I've never
subscribed to any of those sort of like
you know to me regressive ideologies and
stuff that rednecks are stereotypically
known for yeah and I didn't it was never
even really all that weird to me well
I've known for a while now that it's
weird but I'm saying I never even had to
really think about it that's just how I
well I didn't make a conscious decision
to be this you know weirdo thing that I
it's just how it worked out it just
happened which is pretty much I think
how it works for everybody yeah what
really if you had to define what a
redneck is what really is a resident
well a lot of people for some reason
assume that like I'm like opposed to
this guy for whatever reason but I
actually have a lot of respect for him
but I think Jeff Foxworthy defined the
best brought the TV on another team
right now yeah obviously he made a whole
career I was surprised but he got asked
that question a lot of the way he
ultimately like the find it was he said
it's the glorious absence of
sophistication which I pretty well agree
with and in our book that we Robert with
my two roommates Cory and Drew we sort
of added an addendum to that which was
not giving a damn
generally speaking about how people feel
about you and the way you live your life
and whatever you know I mean I'm I do
what I do and I like what I like and I
don't give a damn what you think about
it or not yeah that coupled with the
after mentioned lack of sophistication
is what makes redneck to me yeah so
interesting it's not really even though
I think people prescribed political
leanings to redneck in and of itself
it's not really well just the idea of
sort of yeah I do what I do yeah and
want to be left alone and you know want
to have a good time and all that kind of
stuff and I honestly and I feel so I
guess naive or ignorant or whatever
saying this now but I didn't realize
that to so many people it had those like
political connotations or whatever don't
get me wrong I knew rednecks or
stereotyped as being you know dumb or
you know inbred or I mean racist or
whatever I knew those things existed but
I didn't know that to so many people
like part of the definition of the word
redneck is a regressive racist homophobe
who hates books and loves Jesus not you
don't I mean like that right that's what
it means to people and like nothing else
I didn't realize that that existed at
the level that it does until very
recently yeah and you've done a bunch of
videos on YouTube I think untangling
some of that stuff and showing people
actually no that's not really all there
is to this stuff but how poor did you
grow up because you're white so I assume
you get white privilege did you not have
a little bit white really growing up on
YT so I've actually had to get used to
being white as I've gotten after the
middle class and stuff and a few years
like that's a recent phenomenon for me
yeah I tell people that sometimes it's
true and I know it sounds weird to
people I never felt white growing up I
don't mean to imply that I felt black or
like oh you know what I mean that's not
what I'm saying what I'm saying
is my whole life when I've heard about
white people and what white people do I
thought like you know Connecticut you're
like very yuppie ish like you know the
landed gentry you know I mean my that's
what I thought of an art of white people
and I never
we were white trash which is completely
different you know what I mean like I
point out all the time like a good
example I like to use is cops right and
now don't get me wrong they're not
shooting rednecks in the streets but
it's a well-established thing culturally
that like cops and rednecks don't get
along
you don't mean every of the cops never
made it ghetto or the trailer park yeah
you want to mean so like there was
definitely that feeling of like but I
don't know me no I never felt privileged
at all to answer your question I mean
that's not the same as saying that like
white privilege like exists in a lot of
arenas or whatever it does but I think
if you're poor you know it doesn't
really matter very much yeah the good
thing is though there's a good thing but
if you manage to become not poor and
you're a white man than hey it's just
Isis yeah so now I don't know I don't
know how much you have but you're doing
all right now you're on tour you're
doing big stuff you got on some TV
things cooking now you've you've gotten
yourself out of white trash yes sir I
have yeah I managed to escape but which
is not easy
now you can summer in the Hamptons and
go to Connecticut oh I know I'm not on
that level yet just with the but you
know it's funny about that is my my
whole life I've had this thing where you
mentioned like the Hamptons I've never
been but like I promise you if I wish me
and you went to the Hamptons right now
we like pull and we first get in there
whatever I would immediately become very
uncomfortable and it's an it's an
uncomfortable like I don't belong here
kind of way but then there's also an
element of like they know they're going
to be able to tell like look at me and
tell like who let who let the you know
trailer-trash in here whatever
and I know that that's irrational but I
really do like feel that yes I have yeah
so okay so you grow up white trash
redneck community in Tennessee give me
some of the good stuff about that
because you talked about the good stuff
and the values and that kind of stuff
well nature is a big one like it's
absolutely beautiful there the best part
about my home county is the lake Dale
Hollow Lake objectively awesome lake and
so if you're into any outdoorsy stuff
we've got that in spades and yeah the
sense of like community everybody knows
everybody there's cons for that too
obviously obviously but there's a lot of
good things about it like people
actually genuinely care about each other
for the most part and also the food I'm
a huge fan of you know what I mean like
my my grandmas both of them you know
what most people would call soul food or
whatever I guess but just you know
frying everything whatever else yeah I'm
not good for the arteries but good for
the soul they're you the music I think
the south as far as regions go I think
the South has the best music or produces
the best music in the country and maybe
the world and just the way I mentioned
earlier a lot you know people like to
have a good time you know what I mean
like people are not very tightly wound
there you thought about it's a lot more
like laid-back and just like relaxed
atmosphere and none of that whole like
stereotypical rat race stuff that
happens you don't have any of that it's
weird because sometimes I like neat
there's a part of me that needs that or
wants that trailer I wouldn't be doing
any of this but there's also a part of
me that appreciates that more like
pastoral type thing in my hometown sure
what about it what about some of the the
political stuff when you add that to
this so far we got we got kind of the
good stuff but you know the political
stuff is where people start going I
there are there all backwards old it all
adds up what's weird to me
and I talked to like people from places
like I'm from about this a lot and they
pretty well agree with it like as a kid
growing up Pete
were mostly apolitical I'm not saying
they were like Democrats or anything
like that is just like I don't they
didn't really care it was like it seemed
to be more of an attitude of like ah the
hell with them all you don't have em
they're all full of [ __ ] they don't care
about us yeah you know and I mean and
that was pretty much it
and obviously that has changed but I've
been gone from the town I grew up in for
12 years now and obviously a lot has
changed since I left because it's not
like that didn't exist but I was never
aware of it being this big like cult
cultural dividing factor or whatever
most people just didn't just didn't
really talk about it or whatever as I
was growing up but but then my hometown
is a good example the factory left and
went to Mexico after NAFTA and all that
you know and that the ripple effects of
that we're sort of it took a while for
it to get as bad as it is now and I mean
it's bad and has been bad for years like
over 13 14 percent unemployment or
whatever for over a decade now and
that's just made a lot of people you
know angry frustrated and upset and
whatever else and that wasn't really the
case when I was a kid or not on the
level that it is now and I think that's
really what it's about they've gotten
pissed you know because they're like Way
of life has been you know altered very
negatively yeah a lot of them and so I
think that's where they've gotten so
riled up and mad like they are now yeah
I'm not trying to act like they were
this enlightened group because they
weren't but when I was living there and
growing up there just they didn't have
this like rage but they have now you
know what I mean it just wasn't as much
of a thing yeah so it's kind of weird to
me too honestly does that say something
interesting just about economics in
general like that you grew up around
this but there was a factory so people
were working so even if things weren't
perfect its life its life like everybody
else has then the jobs go away and then
suddenly it actually changes everything
yeah because I mean at anytime you know
obviously you're not unique to celina my
hometown this is the story in most
places like that but so jobs leave and
then the
you know the pills come in or the mass
or whatever drug use the muffins abuse
goes through the roof so does you know
crying like theft whatever things like
that the businesses start shuttering the
downtown area is like you know totally
dilapidated whatever else and it just
brings everybody way down and it's just
this like cycle of horrible [ __ ] okay
that you know and yeah and it really you
know really pisses people off or get
them going or both or whatever yeah all
right so before we go any further I feel
like I have to get your liberal cred too
because I know we're going to talk a
little bit about what we both feel like
happening on the left yeah and I always
say like guys I'm still a liberal I'm
for gay marriage I'm for legalizing
marijuana pro-choice I believe in state
education and then the list goes on I'm
against the death penalty I'm for
reforming prison system or all of that
stuff these are liberal things so
computers lay out some liberal creds so
that ten minutes from now when we get on
some other stuff people go oh wait a
minute see really liberals give me give
me some liberal stuff I agree with
literally everything you just named off
I agree with all of those the sort of
Gateway liberalism for me was equal
rights for gay people because my uncle
is gay yeah and I found that out when I
was like eight or nine and which is when
I found that what gave it was you know I
mean I didn't even know anything about
it before that innocence I learned what
gay men I learned - how your uncle he's
gay okay whatever
yeah but that I started picking up on
things that before just went over my
head that like you know these like
rednecks or whatever I was growing up
around that they were saying or that the
church was saying about gay people and I
immediately didn't like it you know what
I mean and that sort of pushed me in
that direction I think and so that's
always been a big thing for me because I
take it a little personally because my
uncle whom I loved dearly
but and everything else you name's no
prison reform very very against the war
on drugs right so that's another thing
that I feel very strongly about cuz it's
also personal because my mom is a
recovering drug addict who also was a
drug dealer who went to prison
so like I'm all that's very personal to
me - and I completely agree with it
it's part like I'm a believer obviously
it needs to be done the right way but
I'm a believer in universal healthcare I
also am very Pro food stamps and Welfare
and things like that I've always felt
like it would be boldly hypocritical of
me if I wasn't because like I survived
on food stamps as a kid you know what I
mean like what food stamps I don't know
what would have happened to me so you
know I feel like I'm living proof that
those systems can work you know what I
mean and yeah they get abused but that's
just the reality I thought my attitude
towards as always been but what is the
alternative though letting kids go
hungry because I'm not willing to do
that so we got to just put up with some
of the abuses that's how I've looked at
it so yeah in fact I think eventually
we're going to need a universal basic
income because I don't think there's
going to be enough jobs that exist for
the amount of people that we have so I
think it's just just the reality of
where the world is going all me all that
stuff is pretty liberal yeah yeah you're
a liberal I believe it now I believe it
did you see the story this week about
Amazon is going to have a supermarket
with three employees because everything
else is just going to walk in scan your
phone you take it you leave I saw like
they I saw they I think they put it
together is like a promo video or
shopping for that on YouTube that I saw
a couple weeks ago yeah you just you
literally walk in just get whatever you
want throw it in a bag and walk out yeah
because they've got like scanners or
whatever yeah I mean and that kind of
thing is not going away one of the
biggest ones I think everybody realizes
at this point how close we're getting to
self-driving vehicles I mean that's
happening there's no doubt that that's
happening and truck drivers that's like
the number one occupation in something
like 37 of the 50 states in this country
or something like that the most popular
job is a truck driver the minute that
they have Freight that can be fully
automated reliably and safely they will
and all of that will just go away
overnight
yeah and that's going to happen in a lot
of industries too and I'm saying what
else are we going to
I think you know what I mean so I says
how I just think again that's the
reality of it yeah like something like a
universal basic income or do you think
that that would be the answer more than
basically retraining an entire
population to either fix computers or
the robots or the drones or yeah or any
of that that's that may be a breach too
far yeah I yeah I think so
yeah so you're not going to take a truck
driver and having picks and drones just
there's no I'm not and also I think even
if you tried to do that no matter how
many drop drones there are I mean if you
think about let's say like one robot
replaces one person in a job capacity
which is not that's not right we're
actually there anymore way more but even
if it is that yeah I would think that a
maintenance person for that robot would
also take care of 30 other robots you
ought to mean like it's not gonna be
broken down all the time yeah II
understand what I'm saying so you take
the one guy it replaces and he's going
to fix robots now well he's not going to
just fix the one robot that took his job
okay he's going to fix 40 robots so and
and again the reality is one robot
replaces 15 people or whatever yeah when
you just follow that you know that logic
down it just doesn't track for me even
if you wanted to do that retraining of
people whatever else you know numbers
just don't add up to me but I mean I'm
not I'm not an economist I'm a comedian
well I'm talking about that's just what
they got is very good in the scheme of
economics as I understand it I don't
know yeah it's weird to be alive at the
time when we go robot you're going to
replace us you know like we're it's not
science fiction anymore now it's why
yeah oh yeah 20 years from now when they
start talk shows comedians world to be
replaced by robots
yeah and in 20 years it might be less
you know people in San Francisco will be
getting super pissed at Alabama for
having like anti robot laws exact like
that you know I was going to be
discriminating against you know robot
Americans or whatever yeah we're
becoming an episode of Futurama the yeah
yeah yeah it's gonna it's wild
[Music]
you